IS 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
THE WHITE HOUSE ALREADY REELING
FROM A LONG LIST OF PROBLEMS NOW
HAS A NEW LITTLE HEADACHE TO
DEAL WITH, FIRST LADY JILL BIDEN
CAUSING SOME CONTROVERSY FOR NOT
APOLOGIZING TO HISPANIC VOTERS.
>> THIS ORGANIZATION WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE DIVERSITY
OF THIS COMMUNITY AS DISTINCT
AND AS BEAUTIFUL AS THE BLOSSOMS
OF MIAMI AND AS UNIQUE AS THE
BREAKFAST TACOS HERE IN
SAN ANTONIO IS YOUR STRENGTH.
>> Dana: HISTORIC LEE HISPANIC
JOURNALISTS NOT HAPPY SAYING IT
ENCOURAGES THE FIRST LADY AND
HER COMMUNICATIONS TEAM TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITF
OUR PEOPLE AND COMMUNITIES.
WE ARE NOT TACOS.
JILL BIDEN'S PRESS SECRETARY
ISSUING AN APOLOGY.
THE FIRST LADY APOLOGIZES AT HER
WORDS DISPLAYED ANYTHING BUT
PURE ADMIRATION AND LOVE FOR THE
LATINO COMMUNITY, BUT THE FIRST
LADY FINDING SYMPATHY FROM SOME
IN THE MEDIA.
>> THE FIRST THING AS THEY ARE
PROBABLY HUDDLING TODAY, YOU
KNOW JILL BIDEN AND THAT'S NOT
WHO SHE IS.
>> WE ALL, I DON'T KNOW IF WE
ALL HAVE STEPPED IN IT.
I KNOW I HAVE STEPPED IN IT.
SO DR. JILL, JUST WE GET IT, WE
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO, AND JUST TRY NOT TO DO IT
AGAIN.
>> I WANT TO GIVE HER POINTS FOR
SHOWING UP.
BECAUSE FOR FOUR YEARS WE HAD AN
ADMINISTRATION WHERE NOBODY
SHOWED UP.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT.
I THINK THAT PART OF THIS THING,
GREG, WHEN YOU WANT TO EXTEND
GRACE THEN KARMA, YOU SHOULD BE
GIVING THAT TO OTHER PEOPLE AS
WELL.
AND CONSERVATIVES, WE READ
EVERYTHING THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO SAY OR TWEET OR SPEECHES THEY
ARE GOING TO GIVE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT THE CHANCES OF THEM
BEING CANCELED ARE ABOUT 110%.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T MEAN IT, EVEN
IF IT WAS JUST A MISSTATEMENT OR
EVEN IF IT'S A CLUMSY ATTEMPT AT
A JOKE.
>> Greg: PART OF ME SAYS
TURNABOUT IS FAIR PLAY, BUT THE
BIG THING IS PLAYING TO
DIVERSITY IS EMBARRASSING NO
MATTER WHO DOES IT.
AND IT'S WORSE WHEN YOU HAVE TO
APOLOGIZE AFTERWARDS, TRUMP DID
NOT APOLOGIZE OVER THE TACO
SALAD AS FUNNY AS THAT WAS, BUT
I THINK THAT THE ISSUE IS THAT
IT IS TERRIBLE TO COMPARE PEOPLE
TO FOOD OR EVEN MEXICAN FOOD
ESPECIALLY DR. JILL BIDEN, SHE
HAS A MEDICAL DEGREE AND HAS
STATUS AND PRESTIGE, I MEAN, SHE
HAS THE WHOLE ENCHILADA.
AND YOU LOOK AT HER AND IS STILL
QUITE ATTRACTIVE.
I BET IN HER DAY SHE WAS ONE HOT
TAMALE.
LIKE HER HUSBAND WHO IS FALLING
APART LIKE A BURRITO YOU EAT
WHILE DRIVING.
>> Dana: THAT IS DIFFICULT TO
DO.
>> Greg: I GUESS WHAT I'M
SAYING IS SHE SHOULD NOT
APOLOGIZE, SHE DID NOT DO
ANYTHING WRONG, WHENEVER
SOMEBODY SAYS SOMETHING OUT OF
THEIR BEST INTENTIONS, JUST
LEAVE THEM ALONE, BUT I DO GET
AND UNDERSTAND THE DESIRE TO DO
IT.
BUT THE MEDIA LOVES THIS STUFF,
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T PANDER YOU
ARE A BIGOT, AND IF YOU DO, YOU
ARE A BENIGN PATRONIZING BIGOT.
>> Dana: THE INTERESTING THING
WAS THAT IT DID NOT JUST COME
FROM THE RIGHT, IT'S UNUSUAL TO
GO AFTER A FIRST LADY UNLESS YOU
ARE MELANIA TRUMP, BUT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF HISTORIC
HISPANIC JOURNALISTS ARE THE
ONES WHO TOOK OFFENSE.
LIKE THE CALLS COMING FROM
OUTSIDE ON THE LEFT.
>> Jesse: SOMEBODY WHO IS
AGILE AND WALKING THE FINE LINES
OF ETHNIC SENSITIVITY IS, I
THINK IT IS OKAY WHAT SHE SAID,
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF HOW SHE
SAID IT.
YOU DON'T GO TO A COLUMBUS DAY
EVENT AND SAY, YOU KNOW, YOU
GUYS ARE LIKE A BUNCH OF
MEATBALLS.
YOU KNOW.
YOU CAN SAY THAT YOU LIKE
ITALIAN FOOD, RIGHT?
THAT IS A DIFFERENCE, BUT AS A
WHITE IRISH CATHOLIC FEMALE FROM
THE EAST COAST SHE COULD'VE GONE
OUT AND SAID MY ANCESTORS MADE A
LOT OF CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS
GREAT COUNTRY, BUT FOOD WAS NOT
ONE OF THEM.
AND THEN YOU SAY IN YOUR CASE,
YOU GUYS MADE SO MANY
CONTRIBUTIONS ESPECIALLY ON THE
CULINARY DEPARTMENT, AS A MATTER
OF FACT OUR HOUSEHOLD, MY
CHILDREN LIKE TACO TUESDAYS
BETTER THAN THANKSGIVING AND
THEN YOU SAY, AND I EXPLAINED
THAT THE PILGRIMS DID NOT EAT
TACOS.
PROBABLY ALIVE, BUT IT DOES NOT
MATTER.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS HAS MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR WHITES TO PANDER
TO ETHNIC GROUPS, BECAUSE YOU
LOOK RIDICULOUS WHEN THEY DO IT,
BECAUSE THEY ARE LIKE I'M THE
GOOD WHITE, I'M THE DEMOCRAT
WHITE.
I LIKE YOUR MUSIC, I LIKE YOUR
FOOD.
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO DO THEM
OCARINA?
LET'S WEAR TRIBAL ROBES AND I
WILL KNEEL WITH YOU AND I KEEP
HOT SAUCE IN MY FIRST.
YOU HAVE TO BE KIDDING ME WITH
THAT, SO THEN THE BLACK
HISPANICS ARE LIKE WILL BE
SCORNING WHITE PEOPLE SHUT UP
AND JUST TELL ME HOW THEY ARE
GOING TO REDUCE GAS PRICES.
SO THIS COULD NOT COME AT A
WORST TIME FOR JOE BIDEN AS HE
IS LOSING HISPANIC VOTES AND HAS
THE ASHLEY DIARY, HUNTER'S
LAPTOP, JILL, WE DID NOT NEED
THIS RIGHT NOW?
WHO IS WRITING YOUR SPEECH?
JESSE WATTERS?
SO IT'S CLUMSY WHEN SHE DOES IT
BECAUSE IT IS BLATANTLY
PANDERING, THE TRUMP TACO THING
WAS COOL BECAUSE IT WAS
TRANSACTIONAL.
HE IS LIKE THEY LOVE ME I GOT
THEM THE MONEY FOR THE HBCS, THE
EVANGELICALS, I PUT THE JUDGES
IN THERE AND WE SAY
MERRY CHRISTMAS AGAIN, THE JEWS,
I MOVED TO THE TO JERUSALEM.
YOU GIVE ME THIS I WILL DO THAT.
BUT WHEN SHE SAYS THAT IT IS
CRINGE.
>> Dana: I THINK ON THIS
POINT, THE PRESIDENT'S APPROVAL
WITH HISPANICS ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" POLL IS 30%
APPROVE, 53% DISAPPROVE AND NOT
BECAUSE OF A LINE ABOUT TACOS,
IT IS ABOUT THE POLICIES, ENERGY
POLICIES, GAS PRICES, INFLATION.
EDUCATION, ET CETERA.
>> Judge Jeanine: BACK TO THE
ANSWER THAT I THINK YOU ARE
ASKING IS THAT THIS IS MINUSCULE
IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS.
THE REASON THAT HE IS AT A LOSS
WITH DEMOCRATS AND I WOULD CALL
LAST WEEK THE 26% OR THE WEEK
BEFORE APPROVAL RATING OF
HISPANICS WAS BECAUSE HE IS NOT
IN FAVOR OF PROTECTING THE
BORDER.
HE IS NOT IN FAVOR OF PROTECTING
THE SAFETY AND SECURITY OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AS IT RELATES TO
CRIME.
HE IS NOT FIGHTING FOR GAS
PRICES.
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT HISPANICS
ARE NO DIFFERENT THAN THE REST
OF US, THEY ARE PEOPLE.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
MONEY IN THE BANK OR MONEY AT
LEAST TO PAY THEIR BILLS AND
THEY WANT FOOD FOR THEIR KIDS
AND THEY WANT THEIR KIDS TO BE
BATHED.
BUT THIS PANDERING, SOME OF IT
IS BIGOTED.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO CRITICIZE
HER, I DON'T THINK SHE MATTERS
IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS.
SHE REALLY DOESN'T.
AND I THINK IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THAT
EVERY TIME MELANIA TRUMP TRIES
TO SHOW UP OR ANYTHING DURING
THE TRUMP YEARS, THEY DESTROYED
HER BEFORE SHE EVEN SHOWED UP
AND THEN THEY SAY, OH, SHE NEVER
SHOWED UP.
SHE TRIED A MILLION TIMES, NO
ONE'S BEFORE THEY MADE FUN OF
OUR FIRST FIVE LANGUAGES.
>> Judge Jeanine: YEAH, AND
THAT SHE WAS ILLITERATE OR
SOMETHING.
MY POINT IS THAT YOU CAN'T
ASSUME THAT YOU HAVE ANY
PARTICULAR GROUP AND YOU CAN
PANDER TO THEM AND YOU CAN'T
SAY, YOU KNOW, IF YOU ARE NOT
BLACK IF YOU DON'T VOTE FOR
JOE BIDEN.
LET IT ALL GO, WE ARE ALL
AMERICANS, JUST LET IT GO.
JOE BIDEN HAD THAT, IT YEARS AGO
DON'T REMEMBER SOMETHING
ABOUT --
I THINK IT WAS THE INDIANS, I
MEAN STOP IT, WE ARE ALL
AMERICANS.
>> Dana: AS JESSE POINTED OUT,
OKAY, THAT'S JUST JOE, BUT IF IT
WAS SOMEBODY ELSE IT WOULD BE
SOMETHING WORSE.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS SOUND BITE
FOR HAROLD, THIS IS ABOUT THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE SEEN IN THE
LAST 35 DAYS OR SO JOE BIDEN AND
THE ADMINISTRATION BEING
ATTACKED BY OTHER DEMOCRATS, SO
HERE IT IS ON THAT.
>> A PRETTY ROTTEN SPRING OF
LUCK, BUT THE PROBLEM WITH THE
YOUNG PEOPLE IS ESPECIALLY
ACCUSED AND YOU ARE RIGHT TO
SIGNAL IT.
IN THE ELECTION JOE BIDEN'S
STRONGEST COHORT WAS A
23-YEAR-OLD, THE YOUNGEST VOTERS
AT 60%, JUST THOUGHT AT 25.
THAT IS IN PART SOME OF THE
OTHER LEADERS OF HIS PARTY ARE
UNDERMINING HIM WITH YOUNGER
VOTERS.
THEY ARE ATTACKING HIM INSTEAD
OF ATTACKING REPUBLICANS.
IT IS AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM.
>> Dana: THAT WAS A LONG WAY
OF SAYING THAT IT'S A PROBLEM
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE ATTACKING
BIDEN.
>> Harold: EVERYBODY GETS THEM
AROUND THE TABLE.
>> Greg: WHAT IS UNDER THE
HAT?
>> Harold: FIRST OF ALL, I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT HAS
BEEN SAID ABOUT JILL BIDEN.
I THINK POLITICS IS PAYBACK ON
TOP OF PAYBACK, AND WHEN IT GETS
SMALLER AND SMALLER AND SMALLER
IN THE INFRACTIONS ARE
INOFFENSIVE, EVEN LESS RELEVANT
OR IMMATERIAL, WE CAN'T HELP
OURSELVES.
IT'S FUNNY COMING OR OPENING.
HE IS -- HE IS RIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
CRITICIZING BIDEN, BIDEN IS
BEING CRITICIZED FOR PURSUING
THEIR WAY OF POLITICS.
I'M SORRY, THE PROGRESSIVES, THE
PROGRESSIVES ARE SAYING HE IS
NOT PROGRESSIVE ENOUGH.
IF I AM JOE BIDEN I KIND OF LIKE
WARY US, BECAUSE OF THE
PROGRESSIVES ARE ATTACKING YOU
AND THE REPUBLICANS ARE
ATTACKING YOU, THAT MEANS YOU
ARE PROBABLY WHERE THE MAJORITY
OF THE COUNTRY IS, WHICH ARE
THOSE THAT THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE 16 OUT OF 20
WEEKS.
THOSE THAT THINK WE MIGHT HAVE A
CRIME COMMISSION OR REALLY GOES
AFTER D.A.'S THAT ARE NOT DOING
THEIR JOBS, POLICE CHIEFS THAT
ARE NOT DOING THEIR JOB.
A REAL FOCUS ON INFLATION,
MEANING WE GET BACK TO ENERGY
AND DO THE THINGS THAT WE SHOULD
BE GIVEN THE CERTAINTY TO HAVE.
THIS IS A MOMENT FOR JOE BIDEN
TO BREAK OUT AND IF I WAS THE
WHITE HOUSE I WOULD ENCOURAGE
HIM TO DO THE THINGS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT IN THIS SET AND
YESTERDAY.
DON'T LOOK AT THIS MOMENT AS A
MOMENT OF WEAKNESS, VIEW IT AS A
MOMENT OF STRENGTH.
TO THE COUNTRY IS WAITING FOR
HIM TO BREAK OUT AND BE THE
PRESIDENT PERMIT DISPOSITION
STANDPOINT THAT WE THOUGHT WE
WERE ELECTING TWO YEARS AGO.
>> Dana: WE SHOULD STAY TUNED,
AND WE SHALL.
UP NEXT, KAMALA HARRIS ROLLING
OUT THE RED CARPE